[Applause] it
is moving fast we can still
catch it before they cross understood the
wall is ahead get ready the cartel
of souls is working with Iran
these new visits to the crossing we change
the strategy listen to voices
I see four vandals I see asan on top
of the wall
[ __ ] ends  to cross we can't
lose him we have to intercept him
[Music]
he ran away
let's chase him
the cartel I'm going to take him to a
safe house in the town we have to
find him understood he
has more friends here than us be
careful
So here we go this way he
is  free move
to the corner
understood I don't see it
open it I managed to
stop the door
[Music]
clear Look they went that way
you're fine not a scratch you I'm ready
dude
But not for long
[Music]
shoot them when they approach
police coming in
[Music]
Colonel the first floor is ready
understood
let's go to the second floor beware of
the enemies
[Music]
[Music  a]
I can't get out
listen to me Hassan left they are
moving it out
[Music]
something is crossing the Atlantic there is a
ship delivering something
[Music]